da ist ein weg
[Musik]
da hätte ich doch einfach mal darauf das
geht überhaupt nichts dran
ich hatte mich bestimmt nicht raus wenn
du so verantwortungslos bis 8 aber wenn
es darum geht mich zu untersuchen und zu
begleiten dann hast du dich gerne raus
losgesagt du hilfst mir nina ich habe
eine arbeite ich habe keine zeit stell
dir vor es gibt andere menschen die
haben auch berufe die gehen arbeiten und
haben trotzdem zeit und manche haben
sogar kinder ja und manche menschen beim
sex besser auf damit sie ihre zeit eben
nicht beim frau nachts verbringen müssen
und dass nina du bist schwanger ja dann
herzlichen glückwunsch
ich kann jetzt hinkriegen weißt du was
darin wird nicht verlassen yahoo
wahnsinn wie du dich für mein leben
interessiert was bedeutet schwanger
[Musik]